[Music]
drex here from drexfactorpoi is sharing
with you the love of boys spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and today i've got another combo for you
all that
is very very heavily based in split time
opposites before we dive in i just want
to give a quick shout out to the friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
flow fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard lane machinski and
becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission so like our
last combo this combo is centered around
the idea of creating movements that
build an intensity and then pay off in
really incredible ways it just so
happens to do that in split time
opposites this time around whereas the
last combo had more transitions back and
forth between different timing and
direction modes so to get down this
combo you're gonna need the following
tricks under your belt number one
anti-spin flowers in split time
opposites
number two zan's diamond in split time
and finally the ability to do pirouettes
with your poi in split time opposites
are you noticing a pattern here
i will leave links to tutorials on how
to do all these different tricks down in
the description as well as up on screen
if you are watching on youtube i'll show
you the combo at full speed then take
you through it step by step and then
show it to you again in slow motion
[Music]
all right so the first piece of this
just starts off with performing
anti-spin flowers in split time
opposites and i want you to notice that
there are these moments when our hands
come together to either side we're going
to be using those moments to begin
building up the tension in this
particular combo the first moment
happens when i bring both of my hands
together over to my right hand side
right there now
i can either separate my two hands again
to keep the flower going or i can do a
little thing where they're going to zoop
kind of zoom on over to my left hand
side almost like they're aborting those
other two petals
if you look at it at full speed it looks
like boom that and then i can keep on my
merry way now the audience knows that
something has happened there but they're
not quite sure what's coming next from
there we're going to go ahead and do the
same thing but when the poi come
together over on the left hand side zoop
like that now again really what this is
is just taking our two poi and hands and
having them do linear extensions back
and forth as we're going across the
midpoint of the flower and if that kind
of reminds you of what goes on in zan's
diamond congratulations you've figured
out the next step of this puzzle namely
after we've gone from both right to left
as well as from left to right our next
move when we get back to the right hand
side is to go full zan's diamond going
across up down
and back and forth yeah now you're going
to want to go back and forth with zan's
diamond several times here really what
i'm trying to get to is that point where
my hands come together over at the right
hand side because that is going to be a
point where we're going to switch things
up namely we're going to try and get to
this right here you can kind of think of
this as being as being splitting the
difference between a split time
butterfly and a waist strap and really
what it just is is
i'm carrying by hands as they do a split
time butterfly back and forth to either
side of me if you look at this from the
sides
the way i was first taught this move was
actually in a workshop that zanmore did
at fire drums where he was teaching
different moves that had diagonal planes
to them and as you can see as i'm taking
this back and forth it kind of starts to
separate out the planes somewhat till we
get that diagonal feel to it and truth
be told trying to find a way to get to
this organically was actually the entire
point of this combo in the first place
so how do we get there well we start off
in zen's diamond here and we're looking
for that moment where we have our two
hands coming together over to the right
hand side right here it's coming from
that place where the right hand is high
and the left hand is low and the hands
converge when we reach this point right
here we actually take it around into
that kind of split butterfly waist strap
right here if you want to see it at full
speed it looks somewhat like this
boom boom boom
it's a seamless transition right
now from here we're going to go ahead
and jump into that pirouettes again
we're going to initiate it from that
point where the two poi and hands are
over at my right hand side right here
the next time around i'm going to boom
take things around and speed up for a
second and finally end it by having my
left hand poi go over my left shoulder
and catching my right hand poi in my
armpits so that entire combo from the
top looks like this we start off with
our split time opposites anti-spin
flowers and we hit the right hand side
boom we shift over to the left with the
left hand side boom we shift over to the
right
now we switch into zan's diamond for a
couple of reps and the next time i bring
my two hands together over at my right
hand side boom that's how i get into my
split time opposites waist wrap here and
off of the right
boom i turn that into a pirouette
things up for a second and bring it to a
rest with my two poi around my shoulders
yeah let's see that again in slow motion
[Music]
cool what'd you think of this one do you
want to pick it up for yourself go ahead
and post video of yourself doing it it
makes me feel like i'm having a good
impact on the world when i see that
happen
go ahead and publish video and you can
tag me i am at drexfactor on instagram
and youtube and i would love to see your
hard work please help me out in that
regard if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe both to help other
people find this video and keep the
conversation going as well as to help my
channel grow this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
of these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons on patreon they
along with the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible do
you like combo tutorials do you like
flow sessions do you like reviews and
tutorials i'm on a mission to try and
bring flow arts and poi spinning to the
wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies through
flow so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that either at the link down in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you're watching on youtube there
you can find a whole host of awesome
rewards and hopefully one of them will
inspire you to sign up and help me out
on this mission please and thank you in
advance and with that dear friends i
take my leave of you i hope you all
enjoy working on this one
if you dug this video i'm going to leave
a link to playlists where i have more
combo tutorials down in the description
as well as up on screen if you're
watching this video on youtube thanks so
much for watching try and make sure and
get out and flow this weekend and i will
see you with a brand new video on monday
peace